thank you so much for coming I'm so
excited to be speaking to you tonight
thank them I would have happily come
anyway so tonight we're going to cover
so like four of your key works in games
but then we're going to be probably
going on side tracks as well so I think
if we could start with the clip from
journey because that's the first one
we're going to talk about that'd be
great
[Music]
Austin Wintory sojourning session 1
[Music]
so journey for many people is like your
big breakthrough game in fact just jump
right on that I'm pretty sure that most
people in the world thought I was a kind
of mid-40s bald guy which in that case
is the delightful conductor oleg contra
denko in macedonia but because that
video went out and it says music by
austin wintery and there's all these
conducting credits and things and then
this comes out I started getting a lot
of messages from people like oh I saw
you in this journey video and so
exciting and I was like mmm we didn't
calculate in advance the identity theft
of a video like this it's always funny
when I look at that I have that random
flashback but yes this for sure was
changed everything
and because she'd already worked with
that game company before you'd already
created the music for Flo so this was
the second time you'd work with them and
obviously this was much bigger so how
did that change did that change the work
in relationship with them how did you
work with the team it I mean they're
unique because they're like this enclave
of artists and so even though the scope
of journey was substantially that was
substantially beyond Flo it's still a
very kind of artists commune style
working environment and there's a lot of
lateral kind of crosstalk so for example
for me the biggest inspiration on the
project was Matt Nava the art director
who also had art directed flower and
then started his own studio after
journey called giant squid and we did
absolute together and so after journey
came out Matt and I were kind of running
around in the press where people say
what was your biggest inspiration for
the music and I would say Oh Matt's
alright but then I'd read an interview
with him or they'd say what's the
biggest inspiration for their I can say
Austin's music because we were sharing a
lot of works in progress with each other
where it just kind of organically seemed
to help did you spend a lot of time
actually in the studio a huge amount I
mean almost you know a lot of the people
I work with are not in Los Angeles but
buy a good luck TDC is so it was three
years on the game
and basically weekly stand up meetings I
would drive down and and and just
sometimes absorb what was going on I had
absolutely nothing new to contribute or
there I had no impending deadlines of my
own milestones but I just wanted to kind
of take in the the survive you know and
the environment and and they're very
artsy as you might expect so they they
would do you know a team lunch where
someone would just come with the slides
of like their trip they had just taken
and show the rest of the team and or
someone would come with a book of poetry
and read you know the idea was I want to
share with all the rest of you things
that kind of inform who I am and you
know next week it'll be that person than
that person that kind of thing and so
did you do what I don't think so
now that you asked yes I think actually
they hate me now that you're making me
yeah I was never quite welcome and they
kept changing the locks and I got around
it no it was it was it was mainly just
about absorbing it was one of those I
was the only member of the team really
other than the the Sony's crew who were
helping us of course like our sound
designer Steve Johnson our music
production team that kind of thing and
the producers but I was the only kind of
core developer team member that was not
a staff that game company person I was
kind of the token freelancer so I was
invited in but always very much as a
guest instead of I was I was kind of the
honorary team member of that game
company but well you had me on that
project when you were developing journey
was that the only project you have
focused on at that time or did you have
lots of other projects that were on the
go yeah I did I had a lot of other
concurrent films you know that would
come and go in a six-week span yeah yeah
that kind of thing typical sort of film
schedules but because journey ran for
three years it was impossible I mean it
couldn't possibly have survived on only
that one job but also creatively you
know I like when if the schedule will
allow it and I can I can logistically
handle multiple projects but with games
that's not uncommon because it's very
often such a protracted schedule that
I'm able to or elongate a schedule I
should say I'm able to you know take a
week off focus on a film and there
you know a two-week period where I'm
doing both where it's kind of like I
alternate every other day or it's like
before lunch is the game and after lunch
is the fill or whatever and I find that
invigorating creatively because it lets
me kind of refresh my perspective by
shifting gears into something wildly
different and actually I worked on
another game called Monaco which is a
wonderful kind of small indie game that
I got hired for before journey shipped
and so there was a period of time where
I was working on both of those and that
couldn't have been more opposite of each
other Monaco is all crazy vaudeville
solo piano and journeys obviously that
about 10,000 degrees removed from that
aesthetic I hope so so how did it how
did you implement the music in geni did
you actually implement it yourself were
you working with the programmer did you
use that mod it well so we were at the
Sony had invested in their own
proprietary music engine called scream
yes which they have happily - smitten
you know said okay to hell with that
that was not a good idea I'm pretty sure
everything is in is in W is now over
there everything I've done certainly
with them since then has been but at the
time we were using scream so we were
completely reliant on their in-house
kind of audio guru the audio everything
guy Monty Mudd unbelievable asset to
journey that guy he was you know very
musical very understanding but also very
deep in the scripting and he and I would
sit for hours and hours and hours
together and and I would also I was
hooked up onto their nightly build
playtests server so every morning I
would make my cup of coffee not unlike
this one and play that nights build
which would usually have yesterday's
mock-ups baked in like I would send the
mock-ups and I had a giant Excel
document of my instructions on how every
single cue should be implemented in all
the different triggers and layers and
stems and all that kind of thing
Monte would put it in there as a mock-up
and I would be able the next morning to
cuff it sip my coffee and play the game
which was awesome and by the time the
game shipped I realized I've played
journey more than anyone alive and I
think for years and years that record
surely had to be true because I must
have logged 10,000 hours of the game and
played every day for three years
and just making sure every single cue is
just right I have to say then that
probably does show actually because
although it's a great soundtrack that
you can actually just listen to as you
would any CD soundtrack but I really
think CDs CDs but I do think when you
actually play the game it elevates the
music it's like all the different they
are the gameplay everything's working
together so in real organ music and it
lifts the arts well it was really lucky
I mean there's so many moments in the
game where they would say you know they
would have a very skeletal kind of
pencil sketch of the design but it
didn't exist even as a prototype yet and
they would say here's the emotion we're
after I mean a perfect example was the
there's a big sequence two-thirds of the
way through the game where you're given
this kind of overview of everything
that's happened it's it's one of the
only sort of actual cutscenes in the
game where it's just this playback of
the of this big panorama that surrounds
the player and it and it's this huge
moment musically but it's one of those
where they just said we want kind of a
big emotional thing we don't really know
what it is so I wrote this piece on the
album we call it the final confluence at
the time it was called like 6m 5-3 for
seven version two or whatever but very
sentimental title like that and they
they heard it before there was any
prototype of the scene or anything like
that and they all kind of stopped and
went well god damn this this is so much
more emotional than we were planning and
I thought sure the next sentence would
be so can he reel it back in but you
know they said no no we need to make the
scene match this this actually gives us
a target before we were aiming way lower
than yeah I mean he said it in a very
flattering way he said something like
the we need to design the scene to do
justice to this music or something which
was really still to this day those kinds
of comments are pretty surreal to me but
there's a lot of moments like that where
I would do something with the score and
they would hear it and say who this
gives us a new idea on how to design
this and so they would they would start
changing the design but then I'd play
that prototype and I'd say oh you know
that initial piece of music I don't
think reflects where you've gone in the
build let me give you another pass so I
would go write a whole new cue or a next
or something and they'd hear that and
say you know this is actually quite
interesting this gives us a new idea of
something we can do with this and then
and then and then I'd play it and say oh
you know I think that music is [ __ ] now
compared to what you've got here I
really should catch up to what and so we
were kind of doing this leap frogging
until Sony intervened as the adults in
the room and said this game has to come
out eventually and so they took it away
from us otherwise I'm pretty sure we'd
still be iterating on it right now how
many iterations did you do in a queue is
average would you say it ranges wildly
from like that sequence I was talking
about where the cameras going around in
a circle that was essentially version
one
I did a tweak later to adjust for a
timing change that they made and then
there's other cues that I wrote probably
north of 20 versions but most of which
were self directed most of which was me
saying it's just not right it's just not
right and then the whole finale
I can I can segue us if you like the
finale of the game which is what you're
primarily hearing in that video went
through a lot of iterations because
including on the gameplay side we almost
cut the whole thing I miss spoiler
you've had six years the game the
character kind of dies on the slopes of
this snowy mountain and everything was
feeling really good about the game and
really locking into place up until that
moment and then what happened after was
just a total train wreck and it was
awful and we couldn't figure out was
wrong and we didn't really know that
that was the point where things were
going wrong it's like we would talk to a
play tester when they finished the whole
game and they'd be like yes okay but
then we were like what we know there's
more here than just that but we're
losing them at some point so we're kind
of building this momentum and then it
falls apart and then the funniest thing
happened my old college roommate was
visiting LA and he said what are you up
to and I said tell you what I got a
meeting why don't you come with me and I
can show you
and so TDC had a little room where they
said you want to play test the game and
just give us your thoughts so this
wasn't one of our official play tests
where Sony has like scorecards and it's
official and they have the cameras
watching the player and you're staring
at their face and awkward and wonderful
and this was just a guy in a room and he
gets to the he get
to the mountain and player collapses and
it flashes to white and then the build
crashes and it just hung on this
all-white screen and he sat there and he
sat there and he sat there and then he
comes out of the room and he has this
look on his face and he's like that was
the most transcendent thing I've ever
experienced in my life and we were like
well [ __ ] the way said you know you
actually the game crashed that's not how
it's supposed to end and he was like oh
it should and and there was this moment
where everyone realized maybe he's right
and then but that's it's sudden he
rebooted the build he played the ending
he was like oh that's crap just stop the
way should I you got divine intervention
on my play test and and don't ignore it
and it made us realize the end is super
flawed and completely back to the
drawing board and same thing with the
music you know I I had tried a variety
of approaches and none of them were
quite working and we were really running
out of time at that point in with
something like three weeks left before
we were locking everything down I just
came in on some Sunday and just kind of
wrote a thing spontaneously and that is
essentially what's there but it lived on
the backs of a lot of dead burned crap
versions do you ever get writes his book
and how did you deal with that ah
honestly no I don't really ever get
writer's block but I don't I hate most
of what I write so I feel like that's
the trade-off in fact I always say to
folks I I I tell people I don't actually
consider myself to be a great composer
because I know that 99% of what I write
is garbage but what I think I'm
reasonably good at is curating the crap
out and knowing like okay this huge pile
can just shove off and this one thing
somehow by some miracle is okay and so I
think my ability to kind of see the
difference is the only thing I can like
claim to positively I think because
writing music is never a problem it's
the right music that's the challenge so
the correct notes you know the rhythms
and harmonies and all those things that
are really damn elusive so yeah
writer's block though has never been
it's vomiting up music is not difficult
I'm gonna move on to our second project
which happens to be one of my favorites
and it's Assassin's Creed syndicate and
I wondered if you could talk about that
because obviously a game like journey I
don't know exactly what the average play
length is mm 90 minutes to two hours or
it's basically meant to be like a film
that the aspiration with journey was
that it would feel more like a poem
whereas most games you could think of
more like a novel yeah pick them up you
come back to them it takes you a week or
a week or a month or however long
journey is if you split journey up
you're kind of like reading hat if you
read the first seven lines of a sonnet
you've kind of blown it yeah and so yeah
the very concise play time so you go
from that and then all of a sudden your
own Assassin's which is ours I mean it's
like nine ten hours and then there's all
the DLC it's this huge yeah we think 30
40 hours when all said and done yeah it
could be law it depends on how
completionists you are you know I have
to resist those games like a junkie
because I'm I'm the guy that you know
like I remember when ac3 came out they
have these damn feathers up in the trees
I hate that that's okay I'll get it
forty hours later I'm only in the second
mission of the game or whatever because
I'm like oh yeah I can't resist that
crap and so yes while the different
beasts wildly different I was going to
ask about how did you get involved in
that project was there a pitching
process yeah that was one of those where
I didn't know anyone involved in advance
our mutual friend Lydia the audio
director called my agent and said we are
looking for a composer for a new title
of course it's all shrouded in secrecy
still at that time and didn't even say
what franchise or anything but they said
you know Austin has a bit of a
reputation for you know coming at things
from a slightly weird angle and we want
something very different for this game
and then subsequently she and I had a
really long phone call where they
revealed this is the next Assassin's
Creed and they said they said you know
we're really proud that Ubisoft of this
franchise but we think it's kind of
showing its age a little bit it's been
10 years and
we want to invigorate it somehow and we
think music and audio can be one of the
ways that we try to inject something new
so they said you know it would you mind
putting together kind of a demo a brief
four pitch of some sort and we're not
were you given did they say it has to be
X Y and Zed it has to give you any notes
very basic guidelines they you know they
said we'd love to hear they gave me a
basic rundown on who the characters were
this twin sibling assassins
and how the game is kind of a
relationship with their father they're
their father who was gone you know the
game has this subtext of them trying to
live up to legacy and so which I also
found immediately compelling because it
was unlike most of the Assassin's Creed
games it wasn't about some Joe nobody
becoming an assassin it was two people
that have all they've been in this
lifestyle forever and you're stepping
into the characters of who who are these
veterans basically already even though
they're quite young and so that made a
big difference knowing that information
in my in my pitch because I said there
should be a cockiness to the music it
should have a almost sarcastic quality
these are too young arrogant very
skilled assassins where 99% of their
foes have no chance of surviving and
they know that and they're super
arrogant about it and so I said the
music should take complete ownership
over that and it should not feel like
danger in fact what if it's like this
kind of McCobb dance of death like a
waltz and Lydia lit up and was like go
on and and of course I was sure that the
phone was gonna hang up because it just
I was starting to go down a rabbit hole
that was so off the path of the other AC
games but she said they gave no musical
references they just said here you know
it's Victorian London it's it's you know
the usual kind of AC assassins versus
Templars end of the world all kinds of
like aliens or whatever the hell it's an
oddly sci-fi franchise but beyond its
poster art you know and so they walked
me through that and I was I'd played all
of them up to that point anyway and they
said so now just hit us with anything
that comes to mind they said we will
give you no creative direction and and
the more you push it
the better and again I thought well I'm
gonna take you at your word and then I
will not get hired and I was shocked
when they called back and said you know
can you start
I mean practical back the next day and
said can you start running tomorrow I
mean it was it was they were shipped all
over herself to make it happen and any
of the ideas that you used in your pitch
did they make it throw into the final
game
the theme is verbatim note-for-note I
didn't in fact I didn't rewrite a single
cue and the whole project after the
first cue I was insane i I don't know
how that happens it's so amazing it's
really rare but Lydia and I just got
into this this synchronicity and the the
music supervisor is this amazing French
Canadian musician and programmer named
Christian he he was incredibly brilliant
and he and I worked together on the wise
implementation very very closely and I
went to them and said you know I've
played all the previous games and I have
a laundry list of things that annoy me
about the way the music is implemented
again I thought that might be very
impolite and they were like please tell
us tell us and because I said you know
drives me nuts that I can whip out my
hidden blade and take someone down in
two seconds and yet it triggers this
dramatic epic action music that sucks
and they said you're you know you're
right and I said so how about you know
we develop an algorithm where below
certain levels of difficulty music
cannot trigger and we go with the less
is more approach and they loved that so
we worked really closely to constantly
play test the game to see you know are
we is the music responding too quickly
and yeah because then it has to stop on
a dime a lot of the times and that kind
of thing and so yeah it was really
really easy surprisingly even though it
was gut-wrenching and I also went
through a lot of Hell personally in my
life during that project it was
shockingly fluid the whole time because
on a game like journey obviously you can
play it enough times that you know
exactly when things are going in you can
really fine-tune it but on a game like
Assassin's it's so big what did you have
a huge delivery list of lots of
different things or don't take more of a
this is a suite ah you know I've done it
both ways I am more of a fan instead of
relying on music editorial process I
really like used to be designed for
exactly what they're written for
and if we need more we need more and so
when all was said and done I wrote about
three and a half hours worth on
syndicate and which was pretty on par
with what we targeted we had originally
aimed for about three hours and so only
went over a little bit and it I think it
works pretty well I mean of course a
game like that is always there's always
more you can add I mean there's a few
cues that play enough times that I'm
like I hate it so much and you know I'd
rather just mute it at this point like
that one cue you know I'm always
emailing them I don't suppose you know
the next update week and they're like
leave us alone the game is done
it's like origins just came out and I'm
sitting here going like oh I have more
notes on second and but ya know it was
it was a you know huge list of you know
combat music mission specific music and
then catch-all you know there's a lot of
deals not DLCs but side mission content
that has its own music and then others
with that group where there's not
specific music for this kind of mission
but there's sort of a group of missions
that fit under a certain umbrella and we
score them collectively and that kind of
thing and on the on the actual
soundtrack album there are a group of
tracks that are probably my favorite on
the album that are actually uses
diegetic music in the game again I just
I love I love them I mean the kids sing
them in the car oh my poor children give
me the reference and for you're not
familiar in singing give me the Cure a
song about someone begging for death
because of poison from a mental asylum
yes yes throw them into the Thames so
their nightmares end those are some of
the lyrics of that one that's great well
I like your family more and more so the
story with that was I mean this was one
of those things that was partially
reactionary the the sea shanties in
Black Flag had proven to be an
unexpectedly popular element of the game
finding them and triggering them when
you're out on your ship and they had put
a lot of energy into recording
like this Canadian college glee club
singing drunken pirate like and and and
like all Assassin's Creed games there
was going to be a huge amount of source
music anyway and and Lydia said being
from London or at least from me I'm
pretty sure from London yeah
particularly not just England but from
the area and she she said you know
there's certain folk traditions and
things that have been going for hundreds
of years and there's certain kinds of
pubs where you hear certain kinds of
songs and she was really hell-bent on
bringing authenticity to that where
1860s London was represented well
through its street performers and
buskers and that kind of thing
and so they were already investing well
over an hour of additional music Justin
to all that and she would send me huge
lists of their vetted folk songs and say
you know can we incorporate these into
the score what do you think of this list
the rest and then about halfway through
the project he said I have a have a
challenge for you so how are you as a
songwriter it was like well I've done it
a few times and what do you got you know
what he got cooking and she said well
there's this genre called the murder
battle it's a real genre of these kind
of macabre Brothers Grimm genre of songs
and the idea is what if there's original
songs in the game but they're
masquerading as period source songs
where some anonymous composer living in
Victorian London is kind of keeps
noticing these figures running along the
roof gradually changing the political
power of London through these targeted
assassinations where she said what if
there's songs that are about what you're
doing but from this vantage point of not
really knowing much about it where
there's an ignorance to like who you are
why you're doing what you're doing but
just someone whose note worthily awful
has just died like in the case it give
me the cure you know the the doctor
running this hospital that's actually
experimenting on its patients you know
therefore you have to target as one of
your missions well it's like you
complete that mission and then as you
wander through certain areas you'll hear
a song reflecting what you just did and
so it was the only time it's ever been
in my career where my deliverable was
sheet music because they were hiring
separate musicians to record all these
different versions and like different
male voices different female versions
fast slow very drunkenly versus very
kind of properly
and it was hilarious and I I had just
finished one of the most amazing things
that ever worked on in my entire life
which is the evening length theater
piece called this gaming life with this
incredible trio of songwriters from
Australia called tripod and I said I'd
love to do this but I want to work with
these these three guys can you hire them
to co-write it with me because if
nothing else they are the best lyricist
I have ever met by far but they're also
quite brilliant songwriters yeah and so
I just sent a couple of the things that
we had done and Ubisoft said great
pulled the trigger and the four of us
wrote those six songs and it was
definitely one of the most fun times
I've ever had in my career so on both of
these games obviously they were recorded
with an orchestra do you have a team
that you work with do you have group of
orchestrators you always use a conductor
or do you conduct yourself mm-hmm well I
conduct myself except in the case of
remote recording which is fairly common
like you saw in journey yeah that was
actually my first time ever doing remote
recording where I'm somewhere in the
world and the musicians are somewhere
else in the world and we're monitoring
through a combination of source connect
and Pro Tools and Skype and so in those
instances I defer her to the local
conductor although in the case of
journey I was so nervous I had never not
conducted my own music before so I
insisted on like a two-hour call with
the conductor the day before and we went
through every single note of every bar
of every cue and I wanted to make sure
that he knew what he was dealing with
and knew where the tricky spots were
gonna be what I thought could be easy
you know what we would need probably
five or six takes up verses one or two
takes that kind of thing and and also
give him a chance to ask me any
questions just since he knew the local
musicians certainly I didn't know them
at all he and I are now we've worked
together so many times that I just send
the parts and we chat 10 minutes before
the downbeat cuz he understands he
briefs them on although oddities they're
about to find all the weird left turns
and harmonies that make musicians often
hate me rather quickly and so I normally
do conduct it though and I have a
wonderful team a copyist I've been
working that he taught music copying in
my college at USC in LA he was the one
who taught us what the industry
standards were for
how your sheet music should look and so
when I got my first gig a month out of
school I called him and said I you know
you just taught me all this stuff but
can you do it and I've been more easy
the only person I've ever worked with
since in more than almost 15 years and
and orchestrations similarly I've got a
team I really really cherish Suzie cider
is my main Orchestrator she and I kind
of tag team the orchestrations usually
and I have a guy whose job title is MIDI
transcription to basically preps the
scores for her so it's a it's a pattern
where I write the cue send it to him he
cleans it up and exports it into
notation software she goes through and
does a Polish pass to try to reconcile
all the little notes I leave her in my
in my da W to make sure the score is
formatted then she sends that to me and
I spend another hour to going through
and changing things and saying well you
know she marked this Forte but I think
it's actually supposed to be like piano
but the samples suck and sounds like
Forte and the mock-up it's really piano
or we go through and I make a lot of
changes on that and I add all the
bowings and blah blah blah and then send
it to the copyist do you get a choice
somewhere where it's recorded or do the
dev teams tell you we're booking air
studios or we're booking Nashville dude
do you get a choice basically yes I've
never had a dev team tell me that kind
of thing but the publisher will often
have requests I mean usually it's it has
to be a buyout recording that's kind of
the only thing they care about so I live
in LA but LA the Union to work with the
local union there is no buyout contract
so I can't record in LA I just there's
no contract available and so but they're
like I don't care if you do you know
Prague or Bratislava or Macedonia or
Nashville or London or anywhere else you
know here's the the brief and here's the
production requirements that were kind
of expecting but how you get there is up
to you now there are I have worked on
projects that were not package deals
where it's being managed through an
audio department like I worked a little
bit with Sony for example on the order
1886 and that was one where the audio
team with whom I'd worked on journey and
and flow they run everything through
in-house so that was actually one where
it's like we've booked air
or Abbey Road and this is where it will
be that kind of thing but generally I'm
left to make those decisions
listen it's fun on that night replay
Dieppe see sure that was definitely one
where Abzu was a rare one where they
yeah that's it all that area the Abzu
just they just said literally do
whatever you want I mean there's no
reference music no it was just just have
at it and I went down a weird well
you'll see there's we were trying to
come up with a good collective noun for
harp you know like it's like a murder of
crows and that kind of so that our
wonderful librarian here Jill Streeter
came up with this beautiful term and
aetherium of harps since we had seven
harps so anyway I guess we can yeah
let's play it play that madness
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so when aBSI came out obviously
comparisons were drawn to Germany
I'm gonna say this is my take on it and
it might be incorrect
so in journey I felt the music as I was
playing the game was very narrative and
you've it actually followed the journey
and it was the emotion that the player
was feeling we actually called the score
the narrator so okay spot-on so far keep
going but with absolute I felt that the
music was themed more about the
locations rather than me yeah I wouldn't
say that yeah actually I would I would
agree with that it is it is more it is
narrative still but the narrative itself
is more abstract so it ends up being
more kind of impressionistic by design
but even though it still actually
hitched to the same basic quality of
following the game's narrative yeah but
but Abzu had a much more kind of fuzzy
goal for the narrative take away you
know journey had a very plotted Joseph
Campbell archetypes kind of structure
and Abzu was going for something much
more kind of ethereal I think and so it
is very locational as a result but it's
kind of an accident almost if that makes
any sense at all I love that when you
saw I went into a new environment in the
music completely changed well I mean the
funny thing journey actually does that
too it's just usually the environment is
so connected to the narrative that you
perceive it as a narrative shift because
the environment is the narrative yeah
and that is actually sort of true in
Abzu as well it's just such a different
beast that I think you perceive it as
being wildly different but it's it's
it's all I mean this anyway I'm learning
about absolute through your questions
and I have no idea what I'm talking
about I don't know where I am right now
great vodka in this coffee though but no
I would freely it was it was
it was such a different process to
unpack and a totally different team of
course other than Matt Nava the art
director from journey now in the
creative director position and so the it
was one of those that as we were going
through I thought oh I bet they're gonna
be kind of natural comparisons to
journey but it never felt we never
really referenced a journey while
working on it and when we did it was
usually like okay here's a moment how
can we make sure it's not journey like
journey esque so we saw the etherium of
hopes you know a thing yeah Oh quote
full credit to Jill for that I love that
was one of the most fun times in the
studio it was great because these
harpists have never done a gig together
I think quite like that or very rarely
at least where it's like because usually
there's one of them right or maybe two
if it's grant Mahler kind of thing but
usually you know they're the one and
they get to kind of own that yeah so I
thought there'd be this territorial like
I'm the harpist you know who the hell
are these other people well there was
screams between them hey well it's true
yes that nothing to do is sound it was
purely for the politics yeah and now I
was it was great fun and they seem to
really enjoy it was like a class reunion
you know like oh my god it's been 10
years and it was great yeah it was it
was awesome and it was really fun also
because it wasn't written like a harp
part seven times like a violin section
it was a harp ensemble so they were
numbered one two three four five six
seven counterclockwise you know like
from from right to left basically in
this almost half circle configuration so
heart for in the exact center was the
kind of concert master this amazing
woman Scylla and so anytime I wanted
just one heart I would usually lean on
harp four cuz she's the you know kind of
the top of the roster but also it put in
the center of the stereo field because
we were dropping them into the mix
exactly how they sat in the room and so
you know there were a lot of times where
I would do harp 1 and 7 only in mirror
of each other so you have this wide open
middle and the extreme left and right
this faint plucking and then I would do
effects where it sweeps left to right
where that would just say on their part
don't play until the person to your left
or to your right has started and I and
there were a few times where I would
actually trigger that manually where I
would just kind of listen
and I would point and then point and
then point and run it down the line and
then queue them off and create these
waves back and forth and all that so it
was so much fun it was you could never
get away with that on most for any other
game probably were there any other
things that were really different that
you added to that school I mean the
whole thing was kind of one big
experiment you know we worked with
London Voices choir as well and it was
one of those where I wanted the whole
score to be generally a bit top-heavy so
the choir was 18 voices 12 Altos and
Sopranos and then six tenors and no
basis whatsoever and the tenors were
constantly up there with the Altos and
so I when we were contracting the choir
I told Ben Perry and Terry that the two
that run the group make sure that you
know your tenors these are proper first
tenors that can sing comfortably way up
high but make sure there's some good
ringers in there too because every now
and again I go as low as I can
comfortably take a tenor and they did
amaze I mean they did the entire score
in six hours and we blasted through all
I mean there was 40 minutes of choral
music or something like that we did it
in six hours I mean it's unbelievable
reading on these music including there's
a pretty tricky acapella choral work
that's sort of the end credits of the
game and it's like a concert piece and I
mean they and they just just did it just
sang it it just it's astonishing to me
even as a musician that people just sit
there and they read the notes and then
just it comes out especially because
there's a lot of them you know nine part
harmony where it's you and the person
next to you on that note and that's it
so you have to have a bunch of confident
singers who can sing out and they don't
kind of lose themselves in the section
the way lesser singers might it was
amazing and yeah and then of all that
had to be mixed of course with a little
dabbling of Orchestra and there was a
bunch of oboe solos that were all
recorded in Florida I found there's this
amazing oboist and Kristen Nagus who
gigs around orchestras in Florida the
Orlando Philharmonic and that kind of
thing but she's a big gamer and talented
musician and so she started putting view
Tube videos online of herself doing
covers of video game music she liked and
so one day I get this email that says
hey check this out and it's an English
horn cover of the theme to journey and
she had made like an orchestral mock-up
backing track for herself that was
pretty well done and then she did that
little game I mentioned Monaco and then
I did
another game that no one played called
horn and wonderful little game but it
sadly no one played it and and she did a
cover of that too so I was like I need
to have this person in my life
yeah and so I reached out to her and
Abzu was a three year period as well and
so at the very beginning I reached out
to her I said you want to record on this
score for you obviously can record at
home like in your living room or however
you're doing it yeah quality is not an
issue so how can we develop a kind of a
pipeline and so she kind of wish was so
initially shocked I think she probably
thought it was a prank call or something
and and then but you know started
recording in three years you know made
her the the star soloist of that game
and then since then she's the word's
gotten out and bazillion colleagues that
feature her left her I'm a Gareth abuses
are heavily as well and and it's amazing
because she also plays four thousand
other instruments to him and she plays
basically all woodwinds I mean including
from all over the world so she's she's
my secret weapon and basically and all
started with Abzu so you mentioned that
there was some games that you worked on
that hadn't been so I monster hits is
that one game for you that you
absolutely loved the music that you
created for it no it just didn't make
there's no way to end that sentence
where my chance is gonna change you
didn't make it okay you enjoyed right in
the music for it oh yeah sure when it
went to market the game was no success
oh been plenty
you know people I'm very lucky that a
quite a few of the games have worked on
did get noticed but people have a
tendency to see only those and but
there's always as there's plenty others
and i won i worked on came out last year
that we emailed a little bit about
called deformers that was made so i
worked a little bit on the order with
jason graves he did ninety-nine percent
of that score and i want to oversell my
involvement but we worked a little
together at the beginning and i had this
wonderful relationship with ready at
dawn the developer and there there's
particularly one of their co-founders is
this guy andre epicene oh who's this
anomaly of a human being because he is a
full-blown like stallone mid 70's
bodybuilder and
no joke if you look up Andreia pasilla
everybody get out your phones look up
Andre he this guy he's like 10 feet tall
and 400 pounds of raw muscle he looks
like Colossus you know I mean it's just
he is a beast and he's like rides Ducati
motorcycles it but he's the chief
technical officer already done he built
their engine from scratch
so he's this brilliant programmer in
physics simulation guru right but he's
also this conservatory trained pianist
he grew up in Italy he's got this thick
accent and he grew up in Italy playing
piano so he's this diehard music lover I
mean you start talking Puccini or Verdi
with him and he'll just burst into tears
at the mention of it and and so I
remember they called me down to talk
about the order and he pulled me aside
from the meeting and had like you know
journey and banner saga stuff and was
asking me to sign it and was asking me
all these questions and we became
immediately really close friends will
have these long nerdy conversations and
so when working on the order he started
on a project that was kind of a tech
demo for himself just for fun that grew
and grew and grew until it became ready
at Dawn's next game which was called
deformers he called me and he said won't
you do the score and I'm that's it
that's all I'm gonna say literally write
anything you want I don't like wheat he
said we don't you know this game is a
much smaller budget than the order but
we've set aside they set aside a
disproportional amount for score for the
size of game that was I mean they really
let me do whatever I wanted and they and
they said the only thing is there's no
storyline whatsoever the game is purely
just blob smashing into each other like
Smash Brothers except it's all about
this physics simulation in a 3d kind of
tilting crazy drunk environment and the
characters are like you're play like a
ball of sushi and things like that I
mean it's totally ridiculous and so he
said he just embraced the insanity and
so I got to write the wackiest weirdest
score I have ever done but if I worked
with this incredible accordion its name
kseniya cedar over recorded her here at
air and a great brass ensemble doing
like turbocharged mariachi music and and
then there's our caster so Kristen she
plays all these in Penny whistles and
bunts ori and all these wonderful
various kind of non-western wind
instruments or non orchestral wind
instruments I should say
it just goes on and on it's the weirdest
most bizarre of whistling like a
spaghetti western that then goes into a
like this very posh waltz and it's just
weird I have no idea how to explain any
of that score it was absolutely blast
and the game came out and was played by
four people and the score heard by maybe
five people but it was I mean absolute
privilege was one of those that it
doesn't matter how many people played it
it was Andrea and I will forever be
brothers I think on that yeah talk about
Christina so I'm gonna move on to the
Banner Saga now and I love the
instrumentation of the Venice circus so
much was she involved in that because I
mean yes yes on the third one horns she
actually only joined in the party on the
third by the time of the third game
which is coming soon let's make it not
one of those that no one ever played but
yeah she is heavily featured as kind of
the central soloist of the third one
except it's not one instrument it's
every time we hear her it's a composite
of four instruments you know we I worked
on a game called absolve er with her in
a similar capacity where we created a
kind of instrument by layering a lot of
instruments and that became our formula
and we kind of approached banner saga 3
in a similar manner but I'm perhaps
getting ahead of myself
on it but yes she needless to say is
heavily featured but otherwise it was
all you know the orchestra in the room
basically
so because it's based on Norse Norse
mythology correct and so how much
research did you do around the
instrumental palette you were gonna use
what instruments you were gonna choose
or was it really just got instinct as do
sort of halfway in between I mean it's
inspired by Norse mythology but it is
not a Norse mythology game so the
characters are kind of Viking esque but
it takes place and a completely made-up
mythical you know almost like
middle-earth or something it's its own
world it's not our world and nor is it
the world of Viking mythology either
which is more or less our world anyway
but I mean other than you know all the
mythology part of it I suppose but
landscape wise and so I was not under
any direction to kind of make it
authentically Viking but even if I had
it
that there's not really much there I
mean it's one of those that
archaeologically they know so little
about what that music would have been
there's a few instruments that have been
recovered from various graves and things
like that and they can infer from their
design what the music might have sounded
like in terms of what speaks best within
the design of that instrument but
there's no certainly no record of
written music or anything like that so
the whole concept of Viking music is
largely a mystery anyway but it wasn't
an issue I did a little research there's
an instrument that is kind of associated
with Vikings called a bucha horn it's
basically just the Lambs like a shofar
it's a lamb's horn that's been hollowed
out and finger holes drilled into it and
there's a musician I know in LA and they
know a Gladstone who's primarily gigs is
a trombonist but like Kristen he loves
to collect instruments and he plays a
thousand different things and he's
always looking for an excuse to buy more
and so I said have you ever heard of a
book horn and of course he was like yeah
and and he says there's one guy on the
planet that makes good ones and you have
to order at six months in advance
because he like raises a lamb and like
harvest is the horn it's the craziest
thing and so I had like two years on the
banner saga so I said well let's put in
an order and he so he literally has a
custom banner saga buku and we used it
on all three games and it's so cool it
can literally only play like six notes
so I was locked into f-sharp minor or
anything compatible with that but I use
it extensively in the score especially
because there's a folk song that scores
almost two different productions there's
the orchestral score but then kind of
like the Murder Ballads concept in AC
there's songs that are even though the
game doesn't ever really get there's no
like vocal lip-sync hearing or anything
like that it's it's like this animated
kind of tapestry there's this
implication that the characters
themselves are singing and it was a
pitch I made to the writers early on or
there's these big gravestones you walk
past that they call the god stones that
honor the kind of lost gods and I said
what if there's text in Icelandic about
these care of these gods and it was one
of those the game had launched initially
as a Kickstarter so we actually the one
of the expensive items was to write the
lore for these characters and they'll
draw the
God based on you and so all these big
bearded Viking looking guys came out of
the woodwork all of whom had a thousand
dollars and so they they all these got
stones are based on these real you know
very brutish looking guys and and they
would develop the mythology themselves
as part of the kind of community
building of the game and so then I would
write lyrics and have them translated
into Icelandic and we recorded various
singers and I also begrudgingly made a
lot of my American singers have to learn
how to phonetically pronounce Icelandic
which turns out is wildly difficult and
and singing it's creating the
implication that's the characters
singing and it's it's it's almost a
whole separate thread but that's where
you really hear the Buckhorn because it
feels like such a folk instrument that
it made sense that it would be almost
like there's an actual Bucca hornist
in the characters of the game somewhere
that kind of thing did you know when you
start on one that it was gonna be there
was gonna be three yeah they pitched it
as a trilogy in fact well and this can
segue into playing these excerpts if you
like because I not only did I know that
but they walked me through the storyline
of all three games in our first meeting
and so I was able to plant I was able to
know where certain themes needed to end
not just at the end of the first game
but by the end of the entire trilogy
which was so nice because if I hadn't
known that I wouldn't have been able to
kind of puppeteer and what I really
wanted to because you know it's it's the
story is a slight spoiler forgive music
it's kind of a love story when all's
said and done and but there are themes
that I introduced very much outside of
the context of what you would think of
as a love theme that then pay off in the
third game that way so it was yeah it
was essential to the process so we're
gonna get a sneak peek now I've been a
saga 3 music I would like that very much
be a lot of fun so we so which do you
want to go with who we have our two our
two I said I said heroes but you said
Geno so show you go for it alright
somebody somebody say number one or two
- okay - so we'll go to know so you lose
that's okay this was on hilah's vote so
alright so
is a it's a theme that you hear in all
three games but you hear it very
minimally in the first two games and
then it becomes essentially the main
theme and actually good call whoever
anonymous helper who yelled to first
that there's also what Christians main
featured role is so you we actually get
to hear the thing we were talking about
and we don't get to do the talking about
music is like dancing about architecture
thing so so that's good so actually what
a play it's very simple
it's an offshoot of the main theme this
is Sir Elton John's piano for [ __ ]
sake so please have some mercy this is
not intimidating so the main theme of
the game is very simple
[Music]
so that's sort of your central theme it
ties it all together so as an offshoot
of that is this theme for this two
characters that are named Juneau and
Ivan who you meet partway through the
first game and they're almost like
wizards or you know like you know
Gandalf type characters called menders
within the inn Velka within the
mythology of the Banner Saga but they're
there they're magic caster types and we
know very little about them for the
first two games and so I wrote a
variation on the main theme that is
something that we whenever they show up
we kind of hint at it so here's how it
sounds
[Music]
very simple I mean usually you just hear
you know it's almost like a folk melody
so okay so I guess let's play the first
yeah first mp3 in the in the Juneau
folder I'll let you know very quickly if
you played the wrong file so this is for
standing here
[Music]
so that's that's when you you're
approaching this tower and that's where
you're about to meet them so I'm able to
play it before we even really know who
it's for so then if you go to the next
one this is the end credits featuring
this amazing singer from Mexico maluca
which was another one of these I just
found on YouTube basically and she's
unbelievable and so I wrote again it's
one of those like the players they don't
know they don't know what they don't
know and this melody is is all about
what's to come but I'm using it just as
like an in credit song so if you play
actually skip two and play the one
that's labeled two point five if you
would
we're in banner saga ones and credits I
just chose two different exits too so I
could decide right now so here's that
same melody but as a vocal piece
[Music]
so that's more obviously this melody so
if you play the next one then this is
from a scene in the very beginning of
Banner Saga 2 which opens it's kind of
like Empire Strikes Back where your
giant climax is actually the opening and
much like the Battle of Hoth is the big
be-all end-all of Empire Strikes Back
similarly there's a huge set piece at
the very opening of Banner Saga - where
the characters are being chased by this
impossibly large army and there's a
canyon they have to cross and that's the
first time we see the power of these
characters of Juno and i tvind where he
uses magic to like float rocks up and
create a kind of temporary bridge and
you have to survive over the course of
crossing this huge canyon so I wrote
this just way over the top cue that
wheels out this theme in a in a you know
appropriately absurd way so yeah so the
next one please number 3
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice and Sunday easy-listening and so
these games by the way are also ones
where they never give me notes they just
let me I just keep getting more and more
like vicious and they're cool man love
it these are I mean there's such dark
games I mean they're basically about the
end of the world but instead of saving
the world is about confronting Death
with Dignity so it's like you know it's
already rather light and fluffy to begin
with
so I guess if we plow right along an
interest of time I'll skip the other
Banner Saga two instances and we'll move
to our exclusive preview never before
heard instances of how that theme shows
up in Banner Saga 3 so if you go to the
one labeled 5 this is where you'll hear
Kristen now and she's playing a
combination of four different like
English horn and this bizarre thing
that's like it it's like a mouthpiece
and broken piece of crap it's it's
called as a foon I mean it's the most
buzzy nasally it's like a broken
saxophone and that merged with like a
bansuri
and and now I'm blanking on the oh and a
recorder like a tenor recorder and we
hybridize those to become this new
instrument and that's and you'll hear
the theme starts to get super weird and
I won't say why because it's a spoiler
so let's hear five
[Music]
we're just going into all kinds of weird
territory on this game it's it's it's
really different from the first two and
and let's just do one just do six seven
eight in succession we'll just finish it
[Music]
so that's more of the orchestra
obviously handling the melody and this
is one of the big kind of payoff scenes
[Music]
and then finally last a little bit of
mayhem saxophones
[Music]
so gives you sense it's weird stuff
everybody's thinking what the story
could be now well you find out in July
it's it's really and you mentioned the
instrumentation I mean it's probably
obvious but this is a big Orchestra that
has no strings of any kind there's no
other than occasional violin solo
tracked separately it's all wins brass
percussion like a college wind band kind
of sound by design all three games were
done that waves really in all three the
third one at air but the first two were
recorded with concert orchestras in
their concert halls with mobile
recording rigs which was also wildly
unlike anything I'd ever done before
it's unique identity though doesn't it I
mean like you know if somebody's playing
banner soccer when you hear the music we
certainly hope but I'll trust you on
that I hope one of the other things I
really liked about the banner saga
because when you play the game it's very
clear the game sort like very much
compartmentalize so you'll get a
cutscene then you'll get the dialog then
you'll get the term pace turn right
right sure yeah the game modes are very
kind of segregated it's very similar
each time and it be very easy to
actually drop into a write on one of
these we're gonna play one of these cues
and then I'll switch at this next
section and when I was playing it I was
trying to be a bit of a geek and how
things were being implemented and I was
like as always writing you down and I
don't know they've done it differently
now over some you'd actually play
continuous cue over all of them
sometimes you change sometimes the
section would have no music how did you
make all those choices cuz I was like
damn that it was a really good idea yeah
well well thank you I'm thrilled that
that's apparent I mean it's for me it's
always about story it's always about the
characters the sort of psychoanalyzing
the characters and and what's their
experience like and so if if the your
characters are in a specific kind of
moment but that moment happens to
stretch across a bit of travel into some
combat then the music should do so
accordingly but if the start of a battle
means a huge shift like if we were in
the middle of a romantic scene and the
battle interrupts that well likewise the
music should reflect that etcetera
etcetera etc to me it's music is
entirely about informing the subtext in
the
Dex is being driven by what's actually
happening so to me mechanics or by
extension location that sort of thing
like I mean location in the very literal
sense like you know the classic would be
you know Zelda game or or or any other
kind of RPG where you have you know your
merchants or your town that you go back
to and it's one of my biggest pet peeves
ever when you keep going back to a
location it's just the same queue over
and over and over and over again as much
as some of those cues like you think of
gerudo valley from ocarina a tiny nor
well some of those little islands of
music have become quite beloved i think
they're bad storytelling because if I go
to Gerudo Valley as link at the
beginning of the game and then I come
back 20 hours later as like link who's
seen [ __ ] man
Garuda Valley shouldn't feel the same
it's a different thing now you know and
and so to me that storytelling is is
should be at the forefront of every
decision you make and so often I'm
saying you know if I have know if there
is no narrative significance of a place
the first time I go to what if there's
no music what if the music has to be
earned or if nothing else the music
should change quite a lot and of course
on Assassin's Creed you can imagine this
was a big challenge because it is an
open-world game and so we tied a lot of
the location-specific music to the
narrative where it had multiple versions
of a queue depending on where you were
within the narrative when you went there
which required a lot of extra music to
be able to do but that to me it was like
okay this way at least if I get into a
fight in front of this pub in front of
you know Buckingham Palace not that
there's a proliferation of pubs in front
of the Buckingham Palace but you know
what I mean if it's at the beginning of
the game where all the enemies are gonna
be super high level beyond me versus at
the end that should be where I'm on par
with them now that's a very different
emotional experience for jacob and evie
and it's the same in the Banner Saga
even though that's a much more linear
it's not open-world by any means still
that that that's the modus operandi for
me on all projects film game whatever
it's it's it's how am i joining with
these storytellers to help their
storytelling yeah and make the music
very dogmatically about that when it
comes to except deformers has no story
when it comes to film versus game
obviously games are interactive what
challenges that does
give you as a composers to how you
actually write your music having to
write for this interactive medium
thinking about how things are gonna
branch or crossfire you do yeah well
that's obviously that's you hit you nail
it with even just the phrasing of the
question it's they are on the one hand
because they're both very much about
characters and story or minimum kind of
an experiential sort of atmospheric
quality you know if we're talking about
the most sort of arthouse non-narrative
film for example or game at very minimum
it's still about a kind of implied
narrative through two very very specific
plotted characters and all that kind of
thing storytelling is at the forefront
of the decisions you're making in both
media so in that sense they're very
similar but the technique is wildly
different as a result because yeah the
interactive elements of games which I am
very passionate about going down the
rabbit hole of you know journey was this
thing and unlocked a new dimension of my
personality because I realized just how
crazy I could get with interactive music
because it became about okay what's the
experience I want to make now how the
hell do we figure out how to create a
system that can do that as opposed to
here's the system it's gonna be a base
track that adds drums when you're
running and then crossfades when such
and such thing and like you're handed
the system to compose to instead it was
like let's dream up what the player like
based on our play tests of what the
players behavior is likely to be let's
just see how we can score that to you
know match in this perfect way and then
what then just answer the question of
what system is needed to match it in
fact sometimes what I would do is that I
just video capture myself playing the
game and then I would I'd score a piece
of footage and say okay how can I make
it so that every single time certain
things happen these happen but then
these other things are just kind of cool
happy accidents and then start to kind
of like pull it apart and put it
together but I I don't actually these
days like to rely on in that kind of
because it's still linearizing the
process quite a lot do you um are there
certain tricks that you've learned over
the years that you always come back to
there's there's it's like with me I
really love doing cross-fading different
different stems - sure glorious
intensities
it's a sort like failsafe really like
doing it you've got something that you
you saw like it's your fallback or you
always end up sneaking in like overtime
designer favorite sound effect yeah
exactly like the will home which at this
point is in bad taste I think but but
yes for me there's a few things that
that are very useful time and again one
of them I'm a big fan of I've never
thought of a good and visual analogy the
only thing I can ever think of is you
know the little number lock combos on
luggage where you have you have you know
your row of numbers and then you can see
kind of hidden it partially at an angle
above and below the kind of higher and
lower number I've often conceived of
cues in a structure similar to that
where you have a base cue which would be
like this set of numbers facing you and
then if you scroll one it's kind of
combining that with another cue or you
tilt it the other way but you can't have
it both you can you have to choose one
yeah so it's basically a cue that has a
central foundation and then additive
layers but they're not sort of globally
additive because sometimes you're told
you know write a cue and then can break
it into constituent elements and then
they can be recombined in any possible
combination but I'm not a fan of that
because I mean sometimes that is the
right choice but in general I'm often
not a fan of that because what it means
is the more generic and less perspective
driven the music is the more effective
it is in that kind of environment
because you're just mixing and matching
all these different elements and so I
like things that have a little bit of a
stronger opinion on what's going on in
the game where certain combinations they
don't work that can't work and so I end
up doing that trick on most every game
where it you could almost think of it
like a Y where there's the the sort of
vertical base that's always there and
then you you end up either here or there
or sometimes this multiple it's like a Y
with a lot of tree branches and also
known as a tree
and and that becomes sort of your
approach where you're creating cues that
have constituent elements that are
actually mutually exclusive of each
other and the other thing that's funny
is that sometimes less interactivity
actually is more because if the if a
scene is compelling and the music is
kind of telling a parallel narrative and
sometimes I'll just draw you'll drop
like a 2-minute loop with no stems no
layers no anything sometimes not even a
loop just it plays and then it's then
it's done and the player will have all
these individual proprietary moments
make the moment I put my foot down the
French horns came in well that was
completely by chance but they're
convinced that that was by design and
they loved it but then somebody else was
jumping off the stage when the French
horns came in and that was for them how
that moment was supposed to be and and
the funny thing is that's how quite a
few games were in you know in a prior
era where the technology like you think
of a lot of the Final Fantasy games for
example where so many of the cubes are
just like four or five six minute loops
that just do nothing but sit there and
play and then people have these
extremely emotionally kind of intense
associations with them with their
specific playthrough not realizing that
it's wildly different than other
people's playthroughs which is the
opposite of journey journey is trying to
be like this wizard looking over your
shoulder making you have a very kind of
designed experience and that can be
quite fun too and we leaned a lot on
Assassin's Creed it on that in
Assassin's Creed syndicate of of
realizing that if we invest in the
integrity of the music and we don't mind
it trailing by a second or two out of
sync with the player like we are less
ultra-tight down to the nanosecond of
our interactivity that they may actually
walk away with the same impression so
for me it's like one of the interactive
elements we play with is the degree of
interactivity itself yeah which is you
know kind of a brain twister but the
other thing it's worth mentioning is
that we don't know what the hell we're
doing as an industry and that's exciting
where we're still in such infancy of
this art form but to me I always liken
it to movies in the 30s and 40s you know
so I mean of course a few real genuine
classics had been made
you know you had your Wizard of Oz you
had your Citizen Kane and Casablanca but
there were some major milestones still
ahead there was no sight there was no
Hitchcock you know there was no
Spielberg etc etc so you know anyone who
would regard the high point of cinema in
the 1930s or 40s is just being
conventionally at this point likewise I
think that all of the best of games lies
ahead
you know we've probably they're probably
a few that will endure over time as
early kind of important games but I
think that it's still so young and
that's exciting so all these techniques
were talking about could easily be out
of date yeah especially as we start
getting into something really excites me
is the the the frontier of blending
procedural music with AI and the idea of
being able to where the composer becomes
more like an author of algorithms more
than than what you would traditionally
defined as a composer or at least
combining those because there you get
into a whole new range of possibilities
and it's really exciting to me yeah can
I just quickly get a time check okay I
think it's midnight we walk outdoors FYI
so you're all staying so I just want to
talk about one thing briefly before you
go on and do your performance which is
about the performance how did you t
credibly I proposed yeah howdy TT start
working together so the youth the half
of you two is on hill a Buddhist who's
sitting up here and will join us in a
moment so I we first met through she
lives in Costa Rica I live in Los
Angeles and about two years ago Sony
Santa Monica retweeted this unbelievably
amazing photo of someone cosplaying as
the journey character in sand dunes in
Egypt that was like it looked better
than the game I mean it was I've seen it
yeah and you know because I like every
time something like that would crop up
you know a great cover like like I
mentioned you know Kristen who did this
cover and I reach down and look I want
to know you and there have been a couple
people who made fan art likes beautiful
paintings and whatnot where I reached
out it's like I just want to notice that
someone's really creative and they've
taken the time to make this sort of
homage to something I was a part of and
is really meaningful to me I want to
know more about that person what drove
them to
that and so I was blown away and I
started messaging and I remember I sent
a message as I said you know I'd I'd
love to mail you an album or something
just to show my I don't know if that
even means anything to you but it's like
this this is so amazing this is such
beautiful work and then I found out she
had made this outfit like in ten minutes
before the flight practically I mean it
was it was it was the last second thing
done before flying to Egypt to do like a
comic-con type convention and and she
had been doing a lot of cosplay and very
well-known especially throughout Central
and South America and so then one day we
became friends we just would message
every now and again and hey how's it
going what's going on with you and
sharing just you know stuff what's going
on in life and then sometime a couple
months later I see a video of her in a
gallery or a space of some kind and it's
this time-lapse of her making this
amazing perfect combination of beautiful
and nerdy portrait of Dorothy aider and
and it's like a 90 second or something
video in the time lapse of about a 30
minute period in front of people yeah
and I thought I had spent a lot of time
especially around my in my early 20s
with a painter who was my cousin who
lives and lived in New York she's no
longer with us I'm afraid but incredibly
powerfully influential person on my life
in my outlook on art and she was this
very spiritual painter and and there was
a very emotional sensibility to what she
did and that really informed everything
about my music today I mean I met her
when I was 18 and but I always would and
I watched her pain and it would
sometimes take weeks to create a single
work on a canvas of this size shrouded
in darkness spoiler about what's about
to happen and so I I saw this time-lapse
and it completely blew my mind because I
thought I thought paintings take weeks
I've seen that how on earth is as
possible in a 30 minute period and she
said well you know it's its speed
painting it's it is what it is and I
thought well you know there's probably a
show in this and I was also just eager
for any excuse to meet in person because
she was such an inspiring
artists and and and I was going through
all kinds of hell in my personal life
and she became this anchor for me as
well and kind of in not trivial terms
sort of saved my life
and so this event rolled around called
the music and Games Festival about a
year and a half ago and they asked me
you know we had done journey live there
the year before we did the whole game as
a live staged event were players were
playing the game and we recreated the
score 100% acoustically interactively
exactly as an entire playthrough and
we've been touring that all over and so
this festival said we'd love to have you
back what do you want to do and I
pitched them this idea where I said what
if I play music and we get some other
players and we speedpaint in front of
the audience and I said what if it's
also entirely improvised where we have
no idea what's going to happen both
painting and music of any kind and of
course I hadn't I don't even know if I
discussed this with our Nilla yet I just
kind of threw this out there and
volunteered her and they said great
we'll do it and so we met for the first
time in Washington DC and just basically
sat I sat at the piano and she stood at
the canvas and it's like we're gonna
tell a story but collaboratively and
with no words and we're we have no idea
what the story is and so then we've been
and then it just we later called it loss
or we call it do ghosts dialogues and
Spanish and we've been doing it all over
the world now of and all different kinds
of formats and we are experimenting with
all kinds of things like we've been
talking to voice actor friends about the
idea of there being an improvised a
narrator who's giving their
interpretation of what's going on and
then we've also tried it like we're
doing it in Poland next week or in a few
days with Tina guo the cellist from
journey she's also spectacular
improviser and so we're gonna play
together as well along with a flute
player named Sarandon and and and so
yeah
it's just this wonderful and terrifying
way to make yourself vulnerable to a
very very forgiving audience
and as it's an exploration of pure
creativity and storytelling is the idea
and and it it actually altered forever
my thinking of what music can be because
music was so much about writing and not
about my own on-the-fly performance I'm
not a fan of improvising as a
compositional technique for example I
don't just sit piano and play and then
like pull a is out it's more methodical
than that usually and so this kind of
just loosened me up and made me realize
music can be experience aware but what
if also painting is experiential we're
all used to going to art galleries or
museums or looking online at portfolios
or whatever and you see a painting as a
finished piece but it's not well what if
the painting is not about the finished
piece it's about what you go through to
get there it's a completely new way to
look at painting also so and I when I
suggested that we try that here to my
shock they said yes so is that of
interest to you find folks here are you
interested in seeing us vulnerably put
ourselves at your feet and create on the
fly I mean nervous there for a second
are we going to audience questions first
I hope so do we need to use a mic course
or yes we have a mic coming to the front
so yeah we'll start right here again hi
you don't need me to say that you've
done an incredible amount of work and
what we heard here has been some
spectacular
being that diverse and you've walking
such an affair different jobs these are
something that you currently wake up how
do you think she'd like to do something
like this oh yes definitely so a month
ago I did a Kickstarter for a project
called a light in the void which is
basically a evening length theatrical
Symphony Orchestra concert that's about
colliding science education and a
science appreciation with music and that
was one of those things where science is
my biggest love outside of music and I
said I want to do a show that no one's
ever going to really hire me to do but I
want to basically talk about science
through music
real scientists not science teachers or
science educator like Bill Nye type
people I want the people who are
actually making these breakthroughs to
come join me on stage so I pitched this
gargantuan ly stupidly huge idea and the
Colorado Symphony in the u.s. said we'll
do it and and then I managed to convince
a couple thousand people or 15-under
people or something to give me like a
hundred thousand dollars on Kickstarter
to seed this thing and it's literally
like me and John Hill as part of this
project and I'm working with a filmmaker
to help craft the narrative and we'll
have like the like the Large Hadron
colliders senior experiment designer
will be one of our scientists we have
the Cassini probe lead imaging scientist
the probe that just recently dove into
Saturn's atmosphere after a 15 year
mission heading out there and orbiting
and so this is one of those things that
I have a lot of ideas and there was no
job for them it was its own thing and
had to do it and thank God we live in an
era of the Internet and Kickstarter that
I actually get to do this coming to
twitch October 5th I'm nothing if not
shameless apparently so yes that that's
one there's a lot of others on hill and
I have a lot of other kind of pet
projects that are entirely
non-commercial and that sort of thing
and I also just write concert music
sometimes for myself okay travelers one
more I have this problem often thank you
very much I know there be an audience
here though we were just chatting in the
Banner Saga you've obviously got themes
for different characters so Juno and
evened did you find that you were tying
specific instruments to specific moments
as well such as with a band on the tower
at the bridge other moments you have the
electric guitar coming through yeah the
weird prepared electric guitar from a
guy named Viking Jesus there's just so
many wonderful stories at the Banner
Saga he sawed a guitar in half and we
made a we made an instrument of that
tragic sound not really actually funny
enough it there are it's there are
certain instruments I associate with
certain characters but it's mainly all
expressed by the time of the third game
like you just heard that weird
amalgamation of wind instrument
that you hear playing that Juno Ivan
theme a number of times we don't hear
that combination playing outside of that
so that's an example and and the
prepared electric guitar is something I
so Sandidge redo is something I
associate with the kind of stone metal
villain type characters called the
dredge but otherwise I paint relatively
equally across the board which is
unusual usually I like to tie specific
instruments to characters very
dogmatically like in Assassin's Creed
the violin is jacob frye the cello is
evie frye always that kind of thing yes
all right who is our for not who feels
the mantle of responsibility
I like how you go yeah that's conviction
I love it we also only made it in the
first two rows thanks very much I was
just wondering have you played anything
where you you thought boy I really wish
I'd been a part of that either from a
musical perspective or just remind of a
technical execution like how the music
followed the gameplay or anything like
that it's it's funny i I've been asked
that question actually quite a few times
and generally speaking no because when I
really loved a game of almost always
part of why I really loved it is its
core and the idea of wanting to write my
own is by definition making it lesser
than it is I mean my go-to example for
that it's always Bioshock Garry Schyman
is the composer of that franchise a very
good friend of mine and I think he wrote
landmark scores for those games and I
adore them and the idea of saying boy I
wish I had done Bioshock is to actually
wish Bioshock to be less than it is and
I don't want that my ultimate example my
ultimate favorite sort of game score
ever is Grim Fandango and that's the
same thing like I would I would actively
detract from Grim Fandango if I had
written that score the only thing even
remotely close to this that I could
offer is that another one of my very
all-time favorites is the Mass Effect
franchise and there's a lot of music in
those games that I really love but it
was kind of a technical man
and and they would be the first to say I
mean that was a really challenging game
it's a huge scope relative to its budget
especially the first game and so they
had a kind of unwinnable situation of
needing a lot of content but didn't have
infinite resources to produce it I mean
they just didn't so there there are a
lot of compromises that really shown to
me that drove me nuts as a player who
happens to also kind of understand the
audio tech and I don't really consider
it their fault but it was one of those
that did drive me insane while I was
playing the game even though I still
resulted in loving it but the
translation of that isn't therefore I
wish I had done it like I'm some Savior
that's gonna come in and fix their game
they did an amazing job under the
circumstances and there but there are
occasional moments where I'm like find
myself thinking you know wonder how I
would have handled that or so but it's
it's not it doesn't go so far as wishing
I had it to me the best jobs are the
ones that I never saw coming they have
no precedent they're not me trying to
figure out how to step into someone
else's shoes or something like that
where I get to I get to play an
experiment and and so existing I mean
obviously Assassin's Creed is an
existing franchise I also did a Leisure
Suit Larry game that's an existing
franchise I just finished the game I
can't talk about yet but that's what
four also from an existing franchise and
I enjoy that a lot but to me the blank
slates are the real real real exciting
thing that journeys the absolute is the
banner saga so yeah I don't I don't
really envy I in fact I'll go even
farther to say not only do I not really
Envy my composer friends and colleagues
in that way but one of my favorite
things is celebrating what they do I
mean Jessica curry who I'm sure all of
you are at the concert tomorrow night
here as well Royal Phil doing
PlayStation and concert Jess will be
hosting that and she wrote dear Esther
everybody's gone to the rapture so let
us melt amnesia a machine for pigs all
great scores truly superb much think
she's one of the greatest composers and
artists that I know that I can imagine
and I don't look at her job and say oh
damn I wish I had scored that I'm like I
think I feel goddamn lucky to live in a
world where she made that thing and I
get to play it right on a note could we
give austin a big hand
so I think I'm right wait-wait-wait-wait
and for Adele for Sol graciously dealing
with me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]